so we've prepared this scene to reveal
our new version of cinema and if you
watch very very closely you'll notice
that it's something strangely alive
about her so action there God sees use
your mind they will use this power to
destroy they will never let him go you
will die here nothing's what you have
just seen was not a pre can seen from a
game it was performed live by an actress
and rendered in real-time directly
within the game world marking a
milestone in real-time performance
capture
who said that so if you look on that
side of the stage you'll see that Molina
our actress has just performed the
entire scene live in real-time from
within the hell-blade world creating a
believable digital character that you
can interact with there's been a Holy
Grail since the birth of computer
graphics our team at Epic has been
wanting to prove that this is possible
today using nothing more than consumer
hardware and the power of Unreal Engine
for the first time I was able to have a
conversation with seller from within the
game world it really hit me it meant
that as a director I could set up the
scene and have full control over things
like lighting and cameras and the
effects so if I want out fire to the
scene I can just go let there be fire
and then under the power of this means
that we can tune the performance to the
scene without any green screen in sight
this idea went from concept to proof in
only seven weeks it involved a
collaboration between Unreal Engine
developers epic games the facial
technology of three lateral the live
facial system of cubic motion and the
creatives at Ninja Theory developers of
hell-blade hell-blade is self-published
and independent so we're quite a small
team about 16 people yet we still wanted
to create one of the most believable
characters out there Senna was a Celtic
Warrior on a quest into the Viking
Heartland but as a result of trauma
she's struggling with psychosis and so
we wanted to represent the physical
emotional and mental trials of her
journey
cambridge-based ninja theory took their
actress marina to serbia to three
lateral who specialize in high-end face
scanning and rigging three lateral
scanned over 100 different expressions
from which they constructed a digital
double of milena that could portray
every possible facial expression the
realistic skin Malina was photographed
under several lighting setups to create
a skin shader that could react with
light to simulate wrinkles blood flow
peach fuzz and subsurface scattering a
body was scanned to create a digital
body double and clothing was modeled and
textured by artists
clothing hair and fur were created and
simulated under physics to complete the
character Ninja Theory set have a scene
within the hell-blade world in unreal
with epic helping to make sure the
lighting was both believable and
cinematic Kubik motion in Manchester UK
developed a facial solver that could
translate video of Molina's face
directly onto the facial rig in
real-time
EPIK help stream and synchronize the
face body voice and scene data in real
time within the hell-blade game world
by combining the skills of ninja theory
epic games 3 lateral cubic motion
ikinema and accents I think we've taken
a big step forward in crossing the
uncanny valley and would love to see
what other developers can do with this
technology
in the very near future it means that
virtual characters that are stunningly
real and present will be able to
interact with you in ways that just
weren't possible before going them just
a bit beautiful singing voice is
beautiful or as this marks an exciting
change in terms of what is possible for
game production virtual reality
production and also movie production
when you're actually in virtual reality
and you're looking into the eyes of this
character it really puts you there you
believe that that person is real it
feels like we're one step closer to the
future we imagined
see